don't listen to the propaganda I know
you and I have a mutual friend shadow
child she mentioned that you might be
able to help me I heard someone might
come by but how do I know that you are
that someone you could be anybody did
this shadow child person mention a name
or anything baba Yaga 50 that is what I
was looking for why yes I see that you
have an appointment this evening allow
me to deactivate the security gate for
you it will just take a second so what
is your Reaper handle it's classified
that is such a cool username classified
all right you are good to go thanks
good luck classified extract the data
expose the truth
shadow Charles code appears to have
worked Pritchard I'm inside the blade
good i was worried you might get
sidetracked by some random civilian in
need of a hero i had several enticing
offers but I turned them all down just
for you oh goody according to
construction Records the servers are
located at the top of the blades
funicular in numbered chambers we'll
have to figure out which one is Santos
place like this must have a Clarion
registry if so it would be in the CEOs
office she has an executive suite on the
highest level of the atrium I suggest
you look they're warning the facility's
exterior maintenance hatch is over
routine maintenance of structure
exterior underway
attention facilities exterior
maintenance hatch
members time
diagnostic sequence complete
profibus yeah PG college a seat us
conventional easy day Illuminati double
of GP chicken is eligible
that's right I was not specific details
temperature readings in server chamber
area
parameters cooling systems functioning
normally
Jensen have you found the executive
suite yet this involves a little more
than just typing on a keyboard Francis
I'm working on it well work harder
according to my research the suite was
designed to be isolated from the rest of
the atrium I assume it's intended to
provide even more privacy which means an
extra layer of defenses exactly so be
careful pritchard out access granted
diamond
water pressure registering with
anomaly detected trace proved access
granted
warnings lyst the facilities exterior
maintenance hatch is open routine
maintenance of structure exterior
I'm sorry but it's a
we don't have any indication of making
too much schedule
later this evening
shadow child that thing you wanted me to
do in the blade it's done 1 million
thank-yous you know Leona is the head
engineer you might find something useful
on her computer the password is trust no
one or at least it used to be person
buona fortuna mr. Jensen run ciao
diagnostics
comes complete
commencing diagnostics check well this
is interesting Pritchard what I found a
log that says the vacuum defense system
in the chamber where similar Sarah doc
has died might have been manually
triggered need I remind you that you're
very to gain access to Santa's data not
play detective I suggest you get a move
on
you